30 jahre nach dem mauerfall haben
erschreckend viele aus deutsche welle
eine rechtspopulistische partei gewählt
aus protest weil sie mit dem deutschland
von heute nicht zufrieden sind oder ganz
einfach weil sie nationalistisch denken
doch der erfolg in sachsen und
brandenburg hat für die afg einen preis
er stärkt den extremen flügel
die partei steht jetzt vor
radikalisierung und richtungsstreit ihre
machtpolitischen ziele erreicht die afg
heute nicht nicht stärkste kraft zur
regierungsbildung wird sie nicht
gebraucht dass ihre spitzenkandidaten im
fernsehen wieder daher reden und dem
netz um so schlimmer hetzen dass sie
unverschämt die losungen der friedlichen
revolution klauen hat mehrheit und mitte
der wählerschaft nicht überzeugt cdu und
spd haben mit taktischen fehlern auf den
letzten metern gewonnen
michael kretschmer hat die sachsens cdu
war gemacht im dauer gespräch mit dem
wlan
er holte sein direktmandat im umkämpften
görlitz sein aufwärtstrend stabilisierte
sich jegliche er sich von der afg
abgrenzte in brandenburg konnte die spd
mit dem klassen aber bodenständigen
dietmar woidke das schlimmste verhindern
ein wichtiges signal für die total
verunsicherte sozialdemokratie und die
große koalition im bund der heute
einschließlich der cdu-vorsitzenden
kramp karrenbauer ein wenig stabilität
eingehaucht wurde
die grünen werden stärker können
wahrscheinlich mitregieren aber ihre
wahlergebnisse sind wieder einmal
schwächer als die umfragen die linke
könnte ihre regierungsbeteiligung in
ihrem kern land brandenburg noch
verlieren und damit den status der ost
partei endgültig die afg welle ist nicht
gebrochen
die anliegen ihrer wälder müssen ernst
genommen werden
30 jahre einheit und das land ist noch
lange nicht einig aber die starke
wahlbeteiligung heute zeigt die
demokratie lebt auch im osten und die
botschaft an die afg ist klar es gibt
machbare stabile mehrheiten jenseits der
populisten